[Applause]
[Music]
while I was getting my masters I entered
a pageant it was the Miss Nigeria in
America pageant it's very specific
Nigerian in America two weeks before the
pageant they called and asked what my
talent was now when you're a child of
immigrants you're not allowed to have
talents your only talent is just against
straight A's the only thing I knew to
play on the piano was mary had a little
lamb and I just didn't think that would
cut it so I was like God I need a
lifeline and loud as day I heard the
voice of God say do comedy and I was
like no cuz what am i funny and I heard
Holy Spirit say what else do you have
and so I said I got nothing he's like
well one day you're gonna trust me or
you're not I remember my first joke was
um my Juran's don't know how to whisper
because any time a call comes from
overseas it's always hello can you hear
me yes no I'm hearing you but can you
hear me and I was turning to my mom like
mom everyone can hear you cuz the way
church people laugh and then I was like
am I actually funny not around other
Africans and then the best thing
happened there was a recession so nobody
else had a job so I figured this could
be my only chance to be poor with the
rest of America
would be pursuing entertainment and so I
moved to to start comedy and acting when
I saw the breakdown for Molly on
insecure I jumped at it because it said
dark-skinned black women who's able to
be both corporate and slightly hood I
was like I need to be her when I first
met the real-life Molly we were at a
mutual friend's birthday party and he
says like oh I gotta introduce you to
her and so we go and we kind of look at
each other we like hug they were kind of
going around in a circle like oh my god
you have big eyes - she has big eyes and
then it's like we started like talking
about each others body part and then a
song came on I started dancing she
started dancing and we were like getting
low on the dance floor it's like she
can't dance like name it's so crazy
because we had never met prior to that
we were just like look at us we are
twins we were meant to be and so we
posted a picture with a hashtag she's me
and I am her any feels like I know I did
look good
[Music]
you